I started the podcast 10 years ago and
there are people with Incredible
longevity and not very many but like
Rogan as an example I mean the guy's a
machine and he's very good at what he
does 10 years is also a long time for me
right that's a long time to do one thing
consistently I'm going to continue doing
the podcast but from a growth
perspective I feel like YouTube is
probably one of the more appealing
avenues for growth
currently but offsetting that is a
desire to increasingly be less
publicly visually recognized because
there are compromises that I've made
related to that there are safety issues
there are privacy issues there's lots of
weird stuff that happens I'm not sure I
want to actually I'm quite sure I do not
want to make my face more recognizable
on the counterargument side I know we're
going all over the place no no dude by
the way this is fire okay good this is
fire keep going I want to know on the
counterargument side and this is both a
reason not to do YouTube but also a
reason maybe I'm over evaluating the
risks and I've talked to some folks I
don't want to name them but very
well-known iconic writers photographers
creators who did one thing very very
well one thing which also makes me
question sort of the Jack of all trades
approach that I
think is in some respects a norm now
where you're present
and growing on many many formats but
putting that aside for a second the
halflife of Fame I think is going to
drop
precipitously as algorithm chasing
becomes more and more dominant and more
and more determinant of what is surfaced
in the sense that I would be shocked if
there's ever again someone as dominant
as say Oprah
was for effectively let's just call it
who knows
a third to a half of all the women in
the United States right one person one
show the sort of long tale of
personalization I think has largely
removed that
possibility and if you even think about
like the personal Half-Life which I
think we can extract like studying the
micro to to study the macro because the
macro can seem super intimidating and
abstract and ungraspable if you just
think about your personal experience and
I've talked to friends about this
10 years ago if you got sent some crazy
video from friends like that video would
stick around for a while right it might
be the video that sticks around for like
a week oh my god do you see that crazy
video of the
thing how many of those do you get per
day now right something that would win
the gold medal of the meme Olympics
crushes all the stupid things that you
would have looked at 10 years ago
infinitely more attention grabbing and
the halflife is what 30 seconds 60
seconds so I think Fame as a phenomenon
in most
cases online will have a very very short
halflife and that worries me a bit from
a psychological adaptive perspective
because I think that
means that has Supreme implications for
the sort of dopamine hit like rat
stepping on a cocaine pedal
aspect of content creation right like if
what you do is less and less persistent
meaning it has less and less durability
like what game are you signing up for MH
and what does winning that game look
like these are really critical questions
right okay yeah we're all playing games
right now like Beyond food shelter a
handful of things at the lower rungs of
mle's hierarchy of needs we're all
playing games like what games are you
playing and just as important like what
does winning that game or those games
look like and is that the life you
want and so looking at how things are
developing and maybe this is a very
fancy way of rationalizing
just being older and more fatigued I
don't know but I find where things are
trending super super
worrisome so if I could be long a number
of things I'd be like okay mental health
Therapeutics
dialysis which seems pretty dystopian
but like I would be bury long those
things I think we haven't even seen a
glimpse of some of the mental health
challenges that are on the horizon
so probably a long answer to a very
short question but that informs I think
a certain it's not just calmness
although there's a lot that goes into
that on my side compared to my earlier
self but
a not wanting to rush into committing at
High high
speed in certain directions that are
very appealing right now at face value
I'm like you know what if you have here
we go I'm going to shut the up in a
second it's like here's the thing if I
think about the authors I respect the
most if I think about the
filmmakers I most aspire to be like or
admire the
most they're not playing a volume game
right like Miyazaki who just put out I
think it's the boy in Heron the Japanese
name is like how do you live it's a
totally different name but they put out
great work that is uniquely their own
you watch that movie and if you've seen
other Studio ji Miyazaki movies you're
like that is the signature that could
not be anyone other than Miaki right you
see like a Daniel de Lewis film there
are so many examples of
this these people have unique
capabilities they've harnessed they
don't need to rush right so if I find
myself feeling compelled to rush either
it's a false signal I should ignore or
I'm about to do something that a lot of
other people could
do and that for me is a cue to really
chill the out and be like wait wait
a second let me go back let me read Blue
Ocean strategy let me go back let me
read 820 principle let me go back and
read any number of things I mean I do
like reading let me go back and watch
these following documentaries about
people who really took an unorthodox
path okay and then let me sit down and
ask why do I feel like I
am compelled to
rush
so there you have it wow that was one
that was fire thanks this has
been on my mind nonstop for the last
couple of
months